So I sort of mentioned in passing in my story
about martial law earlier in the show that
the mayor of Portland was teargassed along
with protesters recently by Donald Trump's
federal troops operating under the banner
of homeland security.
But I never really gave you the details of
what happened there.
So not only was Portland Mayor Ted Wheeler
gassed, President Donald Trump seemed to brag
about it.
Here's Donald Trump during an outrageous Fox
News interview.
First of all, notice Trump doesn't even know
the guy's name.
His name is Ted Wheeler.
Trump calls him Wailin and then Sean Hannity
corrects him.
And then Trump brags about Wheeler getting
the hell knocked out of him.
And it's not to be totally honest, it's not
clear if Trump's referring to getting tear
gassed or that he was booed.
But take a look at the clip and then we'll
discuss.
Sen. They were going wild for fifty one days
and we went in and they've done a great job
hunting trip down the courthouse as a big
federal courthouse, gorgeous federal courthouse.
So we went in and we've been very, very strong
and we have this mayor.
Well and I think he's also, he's also the
police commissioner as I understand it, Dale
Aadland, Mayor Wheeler.
And he's he made a fool out of himself as
he wanted to be among the people.
So he went into the crowd and they knocked
the hell out of him.
That was the end of him.
So it was pretty, pretty pathetic.
But we want to go in and help the cities.
We want to help Chicago.
So, indeed, a few days ago, Ted Wheeler was
hit with tear gas while he was standing with
protesters near the courthouse.
And just about everything Trump says in that
very short clip is false.
Trump calls the mayor, Wheelin Hannity corrects
him so he gets the guy's name wrong.
Trump says that protesters were going wild
for 51 days.
That's certainly not true.
Again, unless Donald Trump is actually, you
know, some kind of physicist that has a different
conception of what time means.
By no measure have the protesters been going
wild for 51 days.
Trump says the courthouse was going to be
ripped down.
That's not true.
But the really shocking thing here is that
it is so dictatorial and so authoritarian
that Trump is ridiculing Ted Wheeler for being
on the side of the public against the federal
paramilitaries.
In other words, overwhelmingly, people don't
want these federal troops in Portland.
Now, I've gotten a couple e-mails over the
weekend from people saying, you know, David,
you should see that there are like individuals.
Someone told me, although I haven't confirmed
that Brett Weinstein wants the troops there
because he says, you know, the rest of the
country doesn't really understand what's going
on.
I don't.
I don't know if that's true.
I got a few e-mails about that.
Overwhelmingly, people don't want these troops
there.
The mayor doesn't want the troops there.
And the local law enforcement authorities
are not working in conjunction with these
troops and anything that would be called a
cooperative way.
And the mayor, as the citizen is joining the
people.
That's great.
Now, yeah, the mayor was booed by some people
when he did this.
And that relates to, you know, people may
be displeased with the mayor's handling of
the situation, but shouldn't we like it when
elected officials instead of hanging out in
the safety of their ivory towers?
If Portland has our ivory towers, I don't
know.
And making declarations.
Wouldn't it be better if people were joined
by elected officials?
Isn't that what we want to see?
Now, I know that there will be situations
where it doesn't feel genuine.
And when Mitt Romney, a Republican senator,
joined the Black Lives Matter protests wearing
a mask, no less in Washington, D.C., joining
mostly left wingers, let's be honest about
it.
And he was asked, what are you doing here,
Senator?
He said, I'm here because Black Lives Matter.
And he kept his mask on and he did it.
There were people who said, this is disingenuous,
Romney.
This is the guy who is going to lower taxes
on millionaires.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
It's it's Romney.
It is that guy.
He's still a Republican.
But I think it's important when a Republican
says, hey, I have to choose the movement over
my party in this particular case.
I think that it should be applauded, but with
some healthy skepticism that these are still
politicians who are calculating what they
do.
The point is, we should be glad when elected
officials join movements rather than just
sending out messages on Twitter or hanging
out in their office.
And Donald Trump is ridiculing Ted Wheeler
for hearing the voice of the people and joining
them in their peaceful protests.
This isn't getting that much attention, but
it is insanely authoritarian.
The president sits in D.C. and essentially
laughs at a public servant who is joining
people and says he got the hell knocked out
of them.
Again, it's not.
Was that from.
He was teargassed, but it's not clear if Trump
was referring to that.
So we have to recognize this for what it is.
And to follow up on the earlier story about.
Martial law and authoritarianism.
Federal troops are being sent around to different
cities, a growing list of cities to satisfy.
Donald Trump's whims and to, as Trump sees
it, generate chaos that will help get him
reelected.
We just can't allow it to work.
But this is his plan now to get ahead of a
narrative that's being floated already.
If you look in some reactionary and Right-Wing
circles there, you might be shocked by this.
There are some right wingers abandoning their
so-called small government values and saying,
I support the paramilitaries because these
protesters deserve it because they are criminals.
Again, the protesters aren't criminals.
They are protesters.
They are constitutionally protected.
It is speech.
They are peaceably assembling.
And they are asking for the redress of grievances
that they are bringing forward.
If they are criminals, then they are criminals,
right?
Protesters aren't criminals.
Protesters are the patriots here.
And that's the something the right doesn't
want to accept.
The right has attempted to hold the monopoly
on patriotism in the United States for a long
time.
Certainly, I was most exposed to it around
the 2003 Iraq war.
But it's not new.
It's been going on for decades and decades.
The protesters are being patriotic.
They are doing the things that our country
was enshrined upon.
A protester is not a criminal.
Now, I've said before, and I'll repeat it.
Some of you disagree.
Breaking windows at a courthouse is not going
to forward any cause.
And it is a crime.
And you're going to be suffering the consequences
of committing a crime if you do it.
Setting fires to buildings is not going to
further any cause.
And it's a crime.
And you should expect that if you do that,
you are going to be arrested and charged.
And it could be really bad for you.
Martin Luther King was very clear about this.
Martin, there's some very interesting contrast,
lookup videos of interviews with Martin Luther
King and separately with Malcolm X, both of
whom were bringing a lot of different ideas,
forward, valuable ideas.
Martin Luther King differed from Malcolm X
and that Martin Luther King recognized that
when you start using more violent tactics
are seen, destruction of property, etc., even
if you can morally defend it, even if we can
all say an insurance company will pay to rebuild
the building, who cares?
OK, that's aside from the fact that people
could get hurt or killed as bystanders.
Martin Luther King pointed out it often comes
back to hurt exactly the people doing the
protesting.
And when you consider that many of these protests
are overwhelmingly white.
Do we really improve the situation for the
people that we are most trying to help by
introducing elements of violence here, which
may only lead to even rougher treatment by
police of the very people we are trying to
help?
So I do see that as self-destructive.
Right.
This is not a show where if you're tuning
in for me to defend criminality, that's not
this show.
But most of the people are just protesters.
It's moms now who have showed up to back up
the protesters.
And then veterans showed up to back up the
moms who were backing up the protesters.
So we can't let them set.
The narrative of the troops are fine because
it's really mostly criminals there and the
protesters are criminals.
Now, we can't let them set that narrative
and not letting them set the narrative is
just part of part of what we need to be doing
for the
next three months.